between raj's romantic failures
leonard's sidelining from the main cast
and bernadette's increasingly sharp
tongue some of the characters in the big
bang theory had disappointing story arcs
keep watching to find out if your
favorite is on the list in the final
season of the big bang theory sheldon
and amy discover a brand new branch of
physics relating to super asymmetry the
only catch is that it will be decades
before sheldon and amy's theory can be
confirmed with real world results then
they discover that a couple of
scientists named pemberton and campbell
have already found a way to confirm
their theory at first amy and sheldon
are excited to meet them pemberton and
campbell seem equally excited to meet
sheldon and amy they freely admit that
they do not even understand the concept
of super asymmetry
the results of their own experiment
would have been a mystery to them if a
colleague had not shown them amy and
sheldon's papers
this whole thing is actually a gigantic
accident
and so sheldon and amy think they will
be teaming up with pemberton and
campbell to win the nobel prize for
physics but then the latter duo started
claiming in front of the media that they
alone are responsible for theorizing
about and proving super asymmetry
sheldon and amy then have to prove they
were the ones who came up with the
theory
in the dead hooker juxtaposition a new
girl named alicia moves into the same
building as leonard penny and sheldon at
first alicia seems like a taller blonder
better version of penny with a more
successful acting career and also flirts
outrageously with the guys
unfortunately it quickly becomes clear
that alicia is only flirting with the
guys in order to get them to do things
for her for free the guys are too
smitten with alicia to realize her
manipulative nature
they are happy to spend all their free
time running errands for her and fixing
up her apartment the only good thing
about the arrival of alicia was that she
forced penny to realize she shouldn't
take the guys for granted when penny
finally asked alicia to stop emotionally
manipulating them the new girl showed
her true colors she insulted penny and
even got into a physical brawl with her
alicia didn't stick around after that
one episode few people watching were
sorry to see her go
in the wiggly finger catalyst raj was
going through yet another bout of being
single and lonely penny gets sick of
hearing about how miserable he is she
fixes raj up with emily a girl who is
deaf she figured that raja's selective
mutism wouldn't be a problem for a girl
who couldn't hear him at first the
relationship goes well emily seems sweet
and understanding and raj quickly falls
head over heels in love with her
after dating a few weeks raj's friends
begin to notice that he is spending huge
chunks of money to buy emily presents
things get so bad that penny has to tell
raj's parents about his reckless
splurging mr kuthropali and his wife
confront raj and force him to choose
between emily and his monthly allowance
raj chooses to stay with emily but she
dumps him after learning that he can no
longer afford to buy her presents emily
returns in the emotion detection
automation where she tells raj that his
biggest problem is that he allows his
parents to dominate him she also informs
him that she is now dating a fabulously
wealthy man indicating that she has not
given up on her gold digging ways
amy farrah fowler had a lot of character
growth throughout the big bang theory
and not all of it was consistent in the
beginning amy was basically a female
clone of sheldon she was a genius level
intellect who looked down on normal
people and regular social customs
at that time amy's mom mrs fowler had a
brief appearance at the end of the
desperation emanation in that scene mrs
fowler was portrayed as a mild and
well-meaning mom who just wants her
daughter to have a normal life as amy's
characterization changed over time it
was revealed that many of amy's mental
neuroses are a direct result of her
mother's strict upbringing when kathy
bates was recast in the role of mrs
fowler for season 11 her
characterization worsened the show has
revealed that amy's mother forbade her
from doing many normal kid things such
as making friends and being in plays mrs
fowler believed such activities led to
drugs and intercourse she would not let
her husband utter a word and she thought
amy wanted her to die so that she could
inherit the china cutlery
while all the other characters on the
big bang theory settled down and found
love the writers of the show could never
seem to decide on a girl for raj the one
who got closest to the mark before
everything fell apart was emily sweeney
who first appeared in the friendship
turbulence at first emily seems almost
too good to be true she's gorgeous funny
understanding and seems genuinely fond
of raj she even accepts his many
personal flaws instead of reacting to
them negatively like so many women
before her but as emily started
appearing on the show more regularly her
perfect facade started to crack she was
revealed to have a twisted sense of
humor that raj often found disturbing
emily also initially and unnecessarily
saw penny as a rival for raja's
affections after she and raj broke up
emily tried to emotionally manipulate
him until he put his foot down when
emily made her final appearance in the
emotion detection automation she hinted
that she had dumped raj because she did
not enjoy his performance in the bedroom
there are plenty of instances of bad
parenting on the big bang theory but
leonard's mom beverly makes all the
other parents look like saints unlike
the other entries on the list beverly
did not start out making a good
impression on the audience leonard often
told stories of his mother withholding
love and affection at a young age this
seems to have led to many of his
emotional hang-ups when beverly did show
up in person she reduced penny to tears
within minutes of meeting her and she
constantly belittled her son's
accomplishments so no original research
[Music]
no
still the episode ended with beverly
loosening up it seemed she and her son
would have a better relationship moving
forward unfortunately that did not end
up happening across her next appearances
on the show beverly continued to be a
cold and emotionally distant mother she
looked down on leonard for his emotional
neediness beverly also largely refused
to accept responsibility for the way her
son turned out as an adult
in the end leonard realized his mother
would never change and that he needed to
stop craving her approval
let's add another name to the list of
girls raj struck out with lucy was a
fellow geek whom raj met at a comic book
store in the tangible affection proof
she was as awkward as raj but the two
managed to strike up a conversation that
turned into a first date like raj lucy
was shy and unconfident this seemed
adorable at first until lucy ditched raj
on their first date it turned out that
lucy was not shy so much as
pathologically avoidant to the extent
she had trouble developing new
relationships or being close with
another person at first raj thinks his
own neuroses are the perfect compliment
to lucy's social anxiety issues but no
matter how hard raj tried to make things
work lucy proved again and again that
she was a flight risk she kept breaking
up whenever raj tried to take the
relationship to new levels finally lucy
ended things with raj for good his
feelings of heartbreak over the
situation were extreme even the
perpetually peppy penny was disgusted by
how lucy ended things with raj she
shouted at lucy in public in the itchy
brain simulation however the whole
situation did help raj overcome his
selective mutism
raja's sister priya was yet another
attempt by the writers of the big bang
theory to give leonard something to do
in between breakups with penny priya was
like a more competent version of raj she
was smart and empathetic and she stood
up to others when the occasion demanded
it she was generally sweet and caring
toward her loved ones one of the most
impressive things priya does in her time
on the show is to thwart sheldon's will
by employing his own roommate agreement
rulebook against him but there's no but
sheldon that's how the law works
even penny can't help but be jealous as
priya seems to be better than her at
everything and a better fit for leonard
unfortunately priya's golden sheen
begins to wear off over time initially
she is ashamed of introducing leonard to
her parents she also tries to stop
leonard from being friends with his ex
penny and is openly disrespectful of
leonard's more geeky interests in one of
the final times she appeared on the show
leonard almost cheated on priya with
another girl but was able to control
himself that is when priya admitted she
cheated on leonard by sleeping with an
ex and the two broke up
raj started out in the series as simply
an awkward guy who was too shy to talk
to women but the show started making
frequent gay innuendo jokes regarding
raj's relationship with howard it might
explain why the two of you have created
an airsets homosexual marriage
when raj learns that getting drunk
allows him to talk to women he goes
overboard and acts creepily toward his
dates in a drunken haze this was very
out of character raj was originally
characterized as a smart sensitive
self-made astrophysicist as the show
went on he seemed to become clingier and
more dependent on his parents money
he remained single until the very last
episode
the character's actor kunal nair has his
own thoughts on the disappointing end
for raj i find it quite poignant that
the one character that believed in true
love so much was the one who didn't in
the end find it it's beautiful it
doesn't have to be so formulaic that's
what i loved about the show it doesn't
have to be a certain way you know
perhaps the character with the most
wasted potential on the big bang theory
was stuart bloom the owner of the comic
book store when stuart first shows up in
the second season of the show he is
depicted as a rare nerd who is actually
socially competent in his very first
appearance in the hofstadter isotope
stewart is introduced as a small
business owner and a talented artist is
this me
depends do you like it
wow it's really good yes that's you
he draws a skillful sketch of penny and
successfully asks her out on a date
basically stewart is shown as a better
version of leonard without the
insecurities
he wears his nerd status confidently on
his sleeve after howard got married raj
started getting paired with stewart more
often and that was when the latter
character started going downhill
he became as scared of approaching women
as raj lost his business and developed a
bunch of health issues from being a
charming go-getter stewart devolved into
another version of the needy and
desperate raj but with even less success
in life
and also like raj the character's
downward spiral is played for laughs on
the show
when bernadette first showed up on the
big bang theory the biggest issue with
the character was that she was too
low-key bernadette was sweet and
friendly and sympathetic and the perfect
foil for howard the would-be ladies man
after the two got married howard became
a more low-key and temperate character
which seemed to bring out the worst
traits in bernadette bernadette became
more sharp tongued both with howard and
other characters the explanation given
was that bernadette used to be a
babysitter who can be a strict
disciplinarian when the occasion demands
it but gradually that strictness turned
into a full-on bullying her office
colleagues are terrified of crossing her
bernadette is shown to be perfectly
aware of the fear she invokes in her
colleagues and her friends and she
enjoys it the character also starts
bragging about her high paying job and
shading howard for not making as much
money as she does bernadette learns to
calm down a bit after becoming a mom but
bits of her past aggression still manage
to leak out from time to time
people might not remember it now but
there was a time when sheldon was not
the main character on the big bang
theory the show started out being about
leonard's hopeless crush on penny and
his geeky friends getting in the way of
his attempts to woo her over time
leonard and penny started dating and by
the last few seasons they had gotten
married but having a happily ever after
scenario for the two would not have made
for interesting television the
characters continued to evolve within
their marriage but unfortunately not for
the better leonard is shown to have
become a complete doormat he lives in
fear of offending his wife because he
still does not believe himself worthy of
her he is afraid she might someday leave
him this behavior is indicated to be a
result of leonard's troubled
relationship with his mom penny now
replaces his mom as the most important
woman in his life later seasons show
much less of leonard having fun and more
of the other characters making fun of
leonard sadly penny often leads the
charge
in the beginning of the big bang theory
penny was set up as every man's fantasy
she was beautiful but not stuck up about
it she was also genuinely kind and
helpful to leonard as he fumbled his way
around asking her out despite their
differences in personality and interests
leonard and penny ended up in what
seemed to be a loving marriage but that
soon began to change as the marriage
progressed then he started making more
money than leonard as a salesperson for
a pharmaceutical company
suddenly penny's attitude toward leonard
changed from loving and supportive to
bullying and overly critical she no
longer even tried to hide her contempt
for leonard's nerdy hobbies and threw
away his prized toy items without
consulting him penny was also revealed
to have been a bully in high school and
that bullying nature seems to extend to
her current friends many jokes are also
made about penny being a borderline
alcoholic many viewers did not like the
way penny proposed to leonard once in a
drunken haze she then became angry when
he hesitated check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the big bang theory are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]